>> Bret: ♪ ♪
IN TONIGHT'S WHATEVER HAPPENED
TO EFFORTS TO RECOVER AN
AMERICAN MARINE TURNED
JOURNALIST KIDNAPPED IN SEAR YO.
>> THE FIRST THING IN THE
MORNING AND LAST THING AT NIGHT,
ALL DAY LONG.
>> THIS MOTHER'S DAY AS SHE DOES
EVERY DAY, DEBRA WILL BE
THINKING ABOUT HER SON AUSTIN.
>> I PRAY FOR HIM TO BE
STRENGTHENED AND COMFORTED AND
THAT HIS CAPTORS WILL TREAT HIM
HUMANELY.
>> AUSTIN SERVED IN AFGHANISTAN
AS A MARINE AND THEN BECAME A
JOURNALIST AND WAS WORKING IN
SYRIA WHEN HE WAS KIDNAPPED IN
AUGUST OF 2012.
THIS DISTURBING VIDEO WAS THE
LAST THE WORLD SAW OF AUSTIN
WHOSE COMPASSION WAS DISPLAYED
RECENTLY AT HIS ALMA MATER OF
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY.
HIS PARENTS AND THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS OFFERING A
MILLION DOLLARS REWARD LEADING
TO HIS SAFE RETURN, ARE SURE HE
IS ALIVE.
>> I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN 100%
CONFIDENT.
>> AUSTIN IS ALIVE.
HE IS LIVING IN CAPTIVITY.
WE ARE SURE HE WANTS TO COME
HOME AND GET HIS FREEDOM BACK.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT.
>> MARK AND DEBRA SAY THERE HAS
BEEN A NEW MORE AGGRESSIVE
APPROACH SINCE PRESIDENT TRUMP
TOOK OFFICE AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME THEY REVEALED THE PRESIDENT
MADE THEM A PROMISE WHEN THEY
MET HIM IN MARCH.
>> HE SAID WE WILL GET HIM HOME.
>> THAT'S BEEN THE RESPONSE FROM
EVERYONE NUMBER THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE COMMITTED TO BRINGING
HIM HOME.
YOU CAN'T ASK FOR MORE THAN THAT
FROM YOUR OWN GOVERNMENT.
>> THE FIRST THING YOU ARE GOING
TO DO WHEN HE COMES HOME?
>> [LAUGHING].
OH, GIVE HIM A BIG HUG, WHOOP
AND HOLLER.
YEAH.
>> AND MARK AND DEBRA ALSO TOLD
US IN THE TRADITION OF THE
FAMILY HIS SIX SIBLINGS WILL